I have this pet theory that we are
looking at speaking the wrong way around
let's say you at a drinks in that moment
it's very easy to think okay I'm going
to get better at speaking and the way
I'm going to do that is I'm going to be
so charming and charismatic I'm going to
learn how to sit up straight I'm going
to change all of these outside tips and
tricks and then when I have that I'll be
good at speaking social confidence and
Charisma is definitely something that
can be learned it's not necessarily
something that you're born with and
today's guest on Deep dive has a
personal story that illustrates this
really well her name is alienor Hunter
and she's a professional public speaking
coach which is interesting because just
a few years ago she had debilitating
social anxiety to the point that she
couldn't even go to the shops to speak
to a cashier or speak to the hairdresser
that's the thing I hated when I was shy
is that like the popular people are
confident people and I'm not them and
I'm this strange person like sitting on
an island looking at everyone else or a
telescope wishing that I could be like
them and so in this episode we talk
about alien's Journey towards overcoming
social anxiety and shyness we talk about
the various strategies that she learned
in therapy on how to question her
beliefs and how she ultimately got over
her social anxiety and then in the
second half of the podcast we talk more
about tips for public speaking the
problem is not the
problem the problem is your solution to
the problem do I identify as shy can I
push but could I be something else is it
hindering my life I think one of the
biggest mistakes that beginners make
when they're new to speaking is
that oh by the way in case you have not
yet heard my book is about to come out
it's called Feelgood productivity how to
do more what matters to you and it's a
book that I've been working on for the
last 3 years now it's being published at
the end of December 2023 but pre-orders
are actually available and I know people
don't like pre-ordering the book but if
you do pre-order the book and you email
me your receipt you will get completely
free access to a live exclusive event
that I'm hosting in the first weekend of
January of 2024 and this is a live
online Workshop all about annual
planning goal setting and reflection and
so I'm going to be facilitating a group
with hopefully hundreds of people from
all around the world world and we're
going to be going through how to figure
out what to do with our life and how to
turn that into goals for the year and
how to build systems and how to be
consistent with stuff and how to make
sure that we are enjoying the journey
along the way that is purely exclusively
available for people who pre-order the
book as a thank you for our little
community so if you want to check it out
you can check out the book you can maybe
consider pre-ordering it the link will
be down in the video description so Alor
welcome to the podcast um you've had a
pretty interesting experience with
social anxiety I wonder if you can talk
to us a little bit about that please yes
so I I used to be really really shy as a
kid and as a teenager I was so shy that
I couldn't really interact with anyone
that wasn't a friend or my family
because I was afraid of them so
something like going to the supermarket
to buy a bar of chocolate was really
difficult because I was afraid of the
cashier hey I couldn't find the
chocolate then I'd have to ask them and
say where's the chocolate forget that
let's say I find the chocolate and I
walk up to the cashier and I give them
the chocolate bar back in the time we
didn't have the electric machines right
and so they'd say something like that's
2 please and I would have to give them
the 2 p maybe I didn't have the right I
don't know it just felt very very
stressful then the machines came in and
you'd have to call over the cashier
that's even worse so going into
something like Tesco would be terrifying
something like calling up the dentist to
book an appointment would be really
scary because uh I'd be afraid that
they'd say no you don't deserve an
appointment and ringing on the doorbell
remember one time my mom dropped me off
to the dentist and I was not young
anymore I was like 15 and she and she
dropped me off and I walked out the door
and I stood in front of the door and she
was sitting there in the car and I was I
can't press on the doorbell mom you're
going to have to come and press on the
doorbell for me because I'm worried that
when I don't really know what I was
worried of I think I was worried that
when I pressed it they would open it and
I'd have to talk to them and they'd say
no wrong appointment go away your teeth
are too dirty for us I I don't know I
was just terrified of something and so
for most of my kind of childhood and
teenage years I was okay with friends
okay in school
but like day-to-day tasks anything that
involved someone else was terrifying for
me and you and so you use the word shy
yeah like what's the difference between
shy and social anxiety is it or is it
like the same thing for me it's like it
depends on how you want to yeah Define
what you're going through I use the word
shy because it feels more
all-encompassing like more people I feel
can identify with being shy than with
being anxious feels like a scary word
like you've been diagnosed with social
anxiety and you should go you know yeah
get help whereas shy just feels for me
what like what I was going through but I
think socially anxious was also what it
ended up being called yeah yeah because
anxiety has the sort
of anxiety has that aspect of
medicalization applied to it it has
inherently in it it's a medical term
right so it just feels I don't know
scarier yeah yeah and and I would know
like I know a lot of people who would
identify as shy but who wouldn't
identify as socially anxious like I
would have said I was shy when I was
younger but I would have said like
didn't know what the hell social
socially anxious meant yeah um but I
guess shy is also on a spectrum right CU
you
know there are people who are more I
guess shy confident is that is that the
Spectrum there are people who have more
more confidence than others you know if
you know I'd I'd be shy about striking
up conversation with someone on the
train next to me yeah but that's like
pretty normal in London to not do that
um but I wouldn't be shy to talk to a
cashier so there's like some is it fair
to say there's some sort of spectrum
here massively a spectrum and I think
where it becomes anxiety is where it
becomes so debilitating that you can't
live your ordinary life but shyness or
perhaps some people say introversion is
just like a lack of Desire I suppose to
want to to speak to other people it's
not that you can't it's just that like
I'm quite happy sitting here having my
cup of tea and talking to myself you
know it's a different way of looking at
it I think m
so do you think being shy is a bad thing
absolutely not okay absolutely not I
think if we're talking about
shyness uh as a choice kind of in terms
of uh being someone who just likes to
prefers to observe rather than be the
one taking the attention I think it's
amazing thing because so few people
listen you know and I think being shy
gives you kind of a superpower of like I
remember when I was really shy I didn't
really when I actually mean I would say
I was anxious I didn't really have the
ability to walk into a room do what I
just did here before the podcast and
chat to everyone and ask them questions
instead I would just stand there and be
like everyone else is going to talk but
what that meant is that I could watch
everyone and I could intu it kind of
what they were
feeling
and if someone was at dinner over like
that corner at the table I could see
that they wanted the
bread cuz like I can't talk to that I'm
my attention is just completely on
everyone else and I can see that they
want the bread at the time I was too
afraid to go and give them the bread but
now it's now it's a superpower because I
can say oh that person wants the bread
let me go over and talk to them and give
them some
bread okay so it sounds like you're
saying that being being shy initially
starts off as like maybe a sense of fear
but then there's actually
uh benefits to being shy because it
means that you're able to listen and
kind of observe what's happening around
you yeah I think that's what I'm saying
which is that first of all I think it's
normal to be shy okay might be
controversial there I think
that I can understand why it might feel
scary to talk to people
because back in the day when we lived in
tribes
if you didn't get on with your fellow
tribe members if they excommunicated you
to the Jungle or wherever you
were you can't eat you can't hunt you
can't survive without them you can't
look after your children so when people
say public speaking is scarier than
death and all of that stuff I think that
applies to all speaking like it I can
see how it can get so distorted in your
head that if I speak to this person they
reject
me it's going to feel like death you
know so I think yeah shyness is kind of
normal way more normal than we think it
is or anxiety around speaking in some
way I'm kind of using those terms
interchangeably uh that's that's that's
really normal and yeah it is also a
superpower so when we were we were
speaking before the podcast I asked you
what would make this a win for you and
you said something to the effect of if
even one kind of person listening to
this is shy and then realizes realizes
that they don't have to be or they can
become not shy then that would be a win
I guess what I'm getting at is yes there
are there are all these sort of side
benefits to being shy but if someone can
become not shy then at least they have
the option rather than being sort of
forced into a state of being and
sometimes I worry that and like feel
free to push back on this but sometimes
I worry that when people say oh I'm just
shy it's a it's it's a statement that
they believe with with all their with
all their heart and it stops them from
doing the things that they really want
to do and it's like oh I'm I'm 5'6 they
they view it as a statement of fact
rather than as actually it's it's not
like being shy is not quite like I'm 5
with six it's it's not necessarily a
thing that you literally can't do
anything about is that is that fair to
say I think that's fair I think that's
very fair um
I the only thing I might have issue with
is like if you do want if you do enjoy
being shy you have no like if I look
back to when I was 18 right and my mom
was ringing me up once a week and saying
aleno you need help like you're the fact
that you can't so there was this moment
okay there's this moment this is like
the change over a moment I'll tell you
about this this was so the moment at
University where everything changed was
when I put my duvet in storage it was
first first term put my duvet in storage
over the Christmas holidays and I came
back in January and uh this is like
January in the UK it's cold it's likeus
5 and my duvet is in storage
and I have to email the lady who's in
charge of the storage room to have her
find a time that I can come fetch it all
my friends do this easily I somehow miss
out on the times that they're going I
could not email the
lady I wrote it a few times and every
time I wrote the email it
sounded too demanding too pushy too like
I was asking her to open I just I
couldn't write the email and so for two
weeks I slept without a duv at
University wow in minus 5 de D and that
is when my mother rang me and she was
like girl like i' I've gone along with
this thing for a while because I've
known that you you're not ready and she
helped me and she pressed the the
buttons at the dentist and she called up
the hairdresses and she did a lot of the
things that I should have been doing by
myself and it was that moment where she
was like you gave yourself the flu
because you couldn't email someone about
getting a duvet out of
storage it's time for you to get help
and I think it's kind of the answer to
your question there which is like if you
are if it's really inhibiting your life
if you are having to manipulate yourself
in a way to make sure that other people
are doing things for you and your
friends you always do things at the same
time as your friends because they're the
ones who can ask for help and not you if
you find yourself like I I still do have
a lot of extroverted friends because
they're the ones that that can do all
the talking and the phoning and you just
have to follow along then
maybe it is worth checking in with
yourself and
saying like do I identify as shy can I
push butt could I be something else is
it hindering my life
basically do you think it so that that's
quite an extreme point to get to before
deciding I'm going to do something about
this shy
situation do you think if someone
identifies as shy like to me it feels
that just having having more confidence
is is almost always just a good thing to
to aim towards because generally being
if if think that of the spectrum is
being shy to confident obviously any any
virtue taken to excess becomes a vice
and so we we're not talking here about
arrogance and overconfidence and stuff
but generally more more people could do
with having a little bit more confidence
in their lives and most people I suspect
most people would probably say yeah if I
could wave a magic one and magically
become 20% more confident I probably
would um do you think that's fair to say
or because it's it's it sounds like
you're also trying to say that no but
being shy is actually a good thing and
it's only when it gets to the point that
it's causing you to have the flu that it
really becomes a problem well I think
what I'm doing here is I'm kind of
avoiding your your question because I'm
afraid of saying it's bad to be shy
because I don't want people who's
listening I don't people who are
listening to be like oh Al know only
thinks that confident people confidence
is the only way to be like that's the
thing I hated when I was shy is that
like the popular people The Confident
people and I'm not them and I'm this
strange person like sitting on an island
looking at everyone else through a
telescope wishing that I could be like
them like that's what I'm trying to
avoid saying is that it's bad to be shy
and that it's good to be confident cuz I
don't think that's true I do believe
that in uh like looking at your shyness
no matter what spectrum you end on you
it can help improve your confidence but
it's the same for the other side of the
spectrum if you're very outgoing and
very extroverted I also think it's worth
looking at your speaking because uh
because I think that everything that you
all your beliefs all the values all the
ideas the insecurities you have about
yourself I think they come out in the
way that you communicate oh yeah and I
think they come out
in a in kind of ways that you wouldn't
expect
so a an insecurity like I'm not smart
enough for one person can come out as
shyness and I'm not going to say
anything until I say the right thing and
for another person it could come out as
extraversion and I'm going to keep
talking because I'm afraid of the moment
where it goes
silent yeah and so I don't think that
it's like if you're shy you have to get
help but if you're extrovert you don't I
think it's on both sides of the spectrum
you're going to have to face some kind
of insecurity or belief that you have
about yourself nice yeah so there's a
middle way as as in all things nice okay
so you had this experience where you
know you were freezing the cold for two
weeks because you can send an email how
and and now you've become a public
speaking coach so what was the how did
how did that trans transformation begin
so it was very it was quite slow at
first at first I just got help I went to
see someone for social anxiety I think
at the time she called it shinness to
not scare me off but um yes I went to
see some social anxiety and we did a lot
of work on questioning my beliefs that I
had about the world yeah so I'd made up
all of these
rules that I had to follow in order to
be polite things like when you go to
someone's house like today when you
offered me tea the old me would have
said no thank you because I didn't want
to inconvenience you and what ends up
happening is that it's it friends up
being Ruda because you go to someone's
house for a drink and they say would you
like a drink and you say no thank you
not even water no no thank you and so we
tackled a lot of uh rules that I'd come
up with to keep me safe and that took a
few years and I got more extroverted or
or better more comfortable with myself
the more we tackled those rules because
it really was it was the first time i'
thought maybe I'm wrong like maybe maybe
my way of seeing the world isn't the
right way of seeing the world so that
softened that a little bit and about my
gosh five five years later I was working
in a normal job as a tech as a tech in a
tech startup as a data
analyst and I had to start presenting my
stuff to clients and I remember my CEO
he was amazing he said to me when we go
to client meetings you have to ask
questions because otherwise he didn't
say this but otherwise if you sit there
like a lemon people are going to think
you're not interested they're not going
to wonder why you're there and um I used
to get that feedback at school as well
my teachers used to say we don't know if
she's doing well or not because she
never asks questions and I always
thought it was stupid feedback but for
it to come back when I was like 26 years
old I thought okay this is something
I've got to conquer so I had this on my
mind and it was lockdown I think 2021
and you don't know this but I was I
opened up my laptop and I was on YouTube
and this little notification pops us and
says Ali abdal is Live on YouTube right
so I'm like great I love Ali abdal this
will be good quality content I click I
click and you are doing a live coaching
session with Michael and Tristan the
co-founders of Al speaking and they're
coaching you in public
speaking and you guys were playing a
game called triple step which is a game
where you get a random title and you
have these words coming up on the screen
and you have to incorporate them in your
speak on the Fly and you were smashing
it you were incredible and I was looking
at this and I was like this is what I
need this this is this it was like it
was fun you guys were speaking and it
was it was like it wasn't this stressful
overwhelming you've got to talk to
client and ask questions it was finally
like something that looked really happy
and joyful and so I bought that course
you sold me D you you you sold me and
you changed my life there you go I think
I didn't think anyone watched the live
streams back in back in 21 but yeah
seems one of them had an effect yeah um
oh that's nice yeah um okay let's go so
so this so you see you start seeing
someone like a therapist or something
who specializes in social anxiety so
what does this questioning of beliefs
look like like what sort of process do
they take you through I'm trying to
think back now because it was a little
while ago I think I remember a lot of it
was about questioning evidence that I
had for certain thoughts and
beliefs so
we would write down in the week all the
thoughts that I'd had about myself like
I'm not good enough I am bad at speaking
I'm shy people don't like me when I
speak I say silly things I'm a disaster
I'm a failure all of these thoughts that
you have going through your head I would
write them down and then there would be
this column that would be evidence for
and this column that was evidence
against okay and I would have to go out
into the into the world and write down
in that week what was the evidence for
that thought
which I found quite easy you know
someone looked away from me when I was
speaking or someone got distracted or
whatever it is and then the evidence
against that thought did anyone listen
to me when I was speaking did anyone did
I have a fun time did I make a friend
and I found that column really really
hard to start with because uh I
think uh I think what they call it
confirmation b or something you're wired
to look for evidence for the things that
you believe in and so I didn't really I
couldn't look for evidence against but
the more I more I did that the more I I
mean you just see it on paper you're
like I'm not really my beliefs don't
really stack up to the evidence that I
see in my day-to-day life it's an
overwhelming amount of evidence against
the fact that I'm a failure and people
hate me and a very small amount of
evidence for it it doesn't make sense
that I hold on to this belief so tightly
so that was one of the things we
did and I think one of the other things
I remember was uh
something called distancing statement
which I found I still use sometimes I
find it really really helpful it's when
you're having a thought like I am not
good enough let's say I am not good
enough and you're sitting there and
you're like I'm not good enough I'm not
good enough I'm not good enough and I
mean that feels very like direct very
real very heavy yeah
but they asked me to add the phrase I am
thinking that I'm not good enough in
front of it I'm thinking that I'm not
good then you say that five times I'm
thinking that I'm not good enough I'm
think it sort of feels a little bit
lighter and then you add another phrase
I'm noticing that I'm thinking that I'm
not good enough I'm noticing that I'm
thinking that I'm not good enough and
what that does is that it has just like
a little bit of distance between the
thought being right yeah and the thought
just being a thought that you can choose
to believe or a thought that you can let
go and I still use that sometimes when I
get really caught up in imagining
scenarios of me failing teaching a
public speaking class or something I'm
like I'm noticing that I'm thinking that
I might do a bad job here let's put that
aside you know and just noticing and
thinking adding those two phrases makes
it so much lighter for
me I did an interview yesterday with a
psychologist called Julie Smith who's
written a book great book about I have
her book I want to read it I watch all
her shorts it's good I think she's
amazing um we we talked about this so
the the way she describes this is um
apparently there's this film the mosque
with Jim krey where he he gets this like
random piece wood um and it's like some
like wooden mask or something and then
when he puts it close to his face it
suddenly like snaps on and then sort of
controls all his behavior and stuff and
then at some point he sort of takes the
mask off and he holds it at arms length
and he's like oh it's just a piece of
wood yeah and so she was kind of
describing that as being kind of how we
identify with certain thoughts yeah
where if the thought is like up up close
and personal it we you know the thought
that I'm not good enough it's not just a
thought it's a belief it's true it's
like of course it's true but when you do
things like I'm noticing that I'm
thinking that I'm not good enough you
you're able to hold at arms length
you're like you see it for what it is oh
it's just a thought like and a thought
like just because I'm thinking it
doesn't actually mean it's true and it
sounds like the process that you went
through with the therapist of like
evidence for evidence
against I mean so some people say that
writing things down is super helpful in
this context because you know the the
mind is so powerful that if you were to
just try try and doing try and try and
do this in your head to be like well
what's the evidence for me being being a
waste Man versus evidence against the
mind is just too powerful but putting it
down on paper and seeing it written out
where you can't argue with it it's like
okay this is clearly like this this
belief wouldn't hand up or wouldn't
stand up in a court of law yeah and even
writing down sometimes beliefs you feel
they're really easy to hold in your head
when you write them down you're like I
gosh do I really believe that that's
quite powerful am I walking around all
day thinking like I have no
value heavy
stuff um so how long did it how long did
it take to sort of get over some of the
social anxiety that that when when you
started working with the therapist I
don't know how to answer that because I
think it was gradual it was like every
week we would do a challenge or
something and so every week I would get
a little bit better and I think that in
my case I've noticed that confidence is
really uh it's a devious little thing
you kind of get it in one area of your
life and then your insecurities go and
hide in another area I found so like I'd
suddenly become really confident at
going into shops and talking to Cashiers
and I'd have conversations with them but
then I'd realize there was just all this
security when I was at a party in the
evening with friends and it was it was
it kind of shape shifts my insecurities
they'd come out in different ways so I
think it took a lot of time it's like uh
it's like that game whacka all you know
you're like put it down there and it
come out here you know that's what it
felt like I think so how long were you
how long did you see the therapist for
in total I think it was two years in
total and so every week you're sort of
making credal progress towards like
breaking down these limiting beliefs and
becoming more able to have conversations
with people yes and you've got to like
you've got to put the working as well
cuz sometimes you turn up and you've not
really done anything that week and you
know it takes a lot of effort I think
because every week you have challenges
and you have to actually go out and and
do them and not every week you feel like
going to
go give someone5 pounds because um it'll
help you improve your speaking or go and
make a friend or go give a word of
kindness or call your mother like it's a
lot of yeah there a lot of faf is the
English word I'll use that I can imagine
um and then what sort of benefits did
you find in your life as you started
seeing the therapist and sort of slowly
breaking down these these barriers over
time the biggest benefit I saw actually
was more empathy because I think in the
old rigid structure of my life there
were Rights and Wrongs and there was
this is the right way to live your life
and these are the right things to say
and facts are
correct and then as I broke down
basically my entire world view and
everything I believed about myself I
realized that uh life is a lot more
fluid than that there's no rights
there's no wrong there's no right way to
be and so it gave me a lot more empathy
for all my friends and my family and the
ways that they expressed themselves and
the ways that they're struggling and I
think I was just less rigid you know and
uh that probably made me a little bit
more open to speak to people as well bit
more Curious So when you say rigid so
were you thinking that like
people who speak to Cashiers are like
doing a bad thing or some something to
that effect like what was the rigid
belief that you had previously yeah that
sounds that sounds a bit ridiculous when
we say like that uh I think no I think
you are your own harshest critic so when
most of the Judgment was on myself I
wasn't judging other people I was mainly
jealous of other people uh but I do
think uh someone said this to me other
day when you're judging others for
something it's generally because you're
judging yourself for that
thing so if I was judging others for
being too loud or too dramatic it's
generally because I was really afraid of
being loud and dramatic those were my
fears and the more
I looked for evidence to kind
of get rid of my beliefs that were
really limiting the more I the less I
judged myself when I was loud and and
dramatic and the less I judged
others nice and so you said that one of
the benefits was increased empathy and
then sort of at at this point were you
at University were you you did you
started work I was at University and
yeah starting work yeah okay and so sort
of if you hadn't had seen the therapist
how would you have been in the workplace
compared to how you actually were in the
workplace so the thing with how I felt
back then it wasn't
that I couldn't do
anything it was
that it was like being on a kind of on a
knife's edge it was like in between
being between a rock and a hard place
right where the rock is the speaking
that you have to do to the other person
that's scary and the hard place is the
consequence of not doing that thing so
for in the workplace for example uh the
The Rock would be speaking to a client
about some project that we're on that's
I don't want to do that I don't want to
ask some questions but then the hard
place if I don't do that well they're
not going to give me other clients and
I'll probably get tied and so I was kind
of I would have been I think if I hadn't
had this
therapy not it's not that I wouldn't
have been living my life I would have
been
exhausted I would have been permanently
going to sleep feeling like I'd run a
marathon because 10 times a day I had
been dancing on this knife edge in
between my greatest fear is about losing
my job and losing everything that
matters to me and my greatest fears
about talking to people the whole time
and so I think the main thing that I
found in that therapy was just a bit
more like ease and calm and comfort and
less exhaustion yeah it's quite
stressful being in that sort of knife
edge where sort of the the mind is in
overdrive and the body is sort of trying
to be like oh like there's all
these bad things that potentially
happening and you're have having to sort
of straddle those that line yeah do you
do you ever get nervous now before you
speak uh yeah if it's like a big podcast
or if it's um uh yeah if it's a talk
yeah a keynote that I'm giving to a
conference of ah to a conference of real
adults so when I whenever I'm speaking
to people older than me I feel like I
have nothing of value to say to them yes
what if people to people younger than me
who are like students or something I'm
like I'm chill like I've been through
I'm fairly confident with that situation
if I'm speaking to people who are like
beginner YouTubers and I'm doing a
session on how to do YouTube I'm I'm
totally fine because I'm just like very
comfortable in that domain but if I'm
giving a keynote on productivity and
there are for example parents in the
audience I'm just like what the hell do
I know about like I'm just like a like
29-year-old dude like spouting
productivity advice and like I don't
have kids it's like I know that changes
the situation drastically you know had a
had was doing a keyote where they were
sort of average age of the audience was
like 45 they were all like kind of
McKenzie partner type people and
like that I was just like what could
what could I possibly say that would add
value to this this this crowd so then I
kind of somewhat over prepare for the
presentation which is kind of a good
thing but then you know the presentation
happens and people are like oh that was
really good and I'm always like oh no
but like it could have been better and
there's a lot of that sort of stuff that
goes into it yeah yeah yeah do you
remember like was there a peak moment
like before you went on stage or the
night before do you remember a peak
moment of anxiety or
stress today's episode is very kindly
brought to you by hu now I've personally
been using heuel regularly since 2017
when I discovered it in my fifth year of
medical school and if you've not heard
of hu they are a business that creates
convenient affordable meals in a variety
of different forms but all of them are
nutritionally complete so they have the
perfect balance of nutrients carbs
fibers protein and fat and contain 26
vitamins and minerals and they've now
packaged some of their most popular
products into their best seller bundle
so you can try out all the heel products
and see which ones Vibe with you there
is heel black edition which is my
personal favorite because it's really
tasty and it's high protein so 40 g of
protein and all you have to do is add
water or milk and you can shake it up
and take it with you wherever you want
to go the bundle also has heels instant
meals which you make in the microwave
there's heel ready to drink range which
are pre-made shakes in a bottle which is
super handy and I've actually grabbed a
few of these in the airport when I've
been between flights while traveling and
finally you'll also get some of the new
heuel bars which I'm very excited to try
out myself plus if you're a new customer
you get a totally free heel t-shirt and
a Shaker and pot with your first order
now I wouldn't recommend having every
meal as heel because that would get a
bit much but it's a fantastic supplement
to a healthy balanced diet so often for
me I'll have heel either for breakfast
or for lunch where the alternative would
be to otherwise have a relatively
unhealthy breakfast and so heal is a
great way to make sure that you at least
have the basics covered when you are
living a hectic and or busy life hu has
very kindly been a longtime supporter of
the podcast as well and I actually did
an interview with the founder of hu
Julian Hearn which was a great episode
and that's in season one of the Deep
dive podcast so anyway thank you so much
H for sponsoring this episode this
season is Once Again being sponsored
very kindly by trading 212 now people
ask me all the time for investment
advice uh because they see that I've
made money and I've made videos talking
about where I'm investing that money the
thing that Warren Buffett and basically
everyone who's sensible in the space
recommends which is to invest in Broad
stock market index funds which you can
do completely for free using trading 212
trading 212 is a fantastic app that lets
you invest in stocks and shares and
funds in a commission-free fashion and
they've got a bunch of features which
are really helpful which is why I
personally use trading 212 to manage a
portion of my portfolio so firstly
they've got this great pies and auto
invest feature so if you're interested
in potentially getting into investing
what you can do is you can browse the
different pies that different people
have created on the platform so you
might get like a hedge font Trader who's
gone onto the platform and has created a
pie of Investments having done a bunch
of research and stuff and that pie might
be like I don't know 20% Apple 20% Tesla
10% this 10% that but it generally way
more complicated than that and you can
see the performance of that particular
pie of stocks and shares and funds and
then if you want to copy that pie into
your own account you can just copy and
paste it directly in and then you can
invest any amount of money and it will
automatically split it according to the
allocation in the pi so if you wanted to
just play around with £100 and you were
like okay that Pi looks good it will
split out that1 based on the allocations
of the pi which is pretty sick they've
also recently added support for
multicurrency accounts now this is
really helpful because for example if
you invest in the S&P 500 which is a
us-based Index Fund then you won't get
hit with all the various foreign
exchange fees if for example you're
investing from the UK like I do and if
you have an invest or an Isa account
then trading 212 also gives you daily
interest on your uninvested cash in
pounds or Euros or US dollars so if any
of that sounds up your straight then do
please hit the link in the video
description or in the show notes and
that will let you sign up to trading 212
and if you use that link you will also
get a completely free share up to the
value of £1 so it's literally free money
so you might as well so thank you so
much trading 212 for sponsoring this
episode there was this conference I was
speaking at in in America a few months
ago and so I was I was giving the
keynote on day two then I saw the guy
who gave the keynote on day one and he
was he was absolutely phenomenal and he
got a standing ovation and I was just
like oh my God this is like the best
public speaker I've ever seen in my life
and my talk did not measure up in the
slightest and while I was sitting there
I was enjoying his presentation and I
was also just like oh my god there like
it's literally impossible to follow this
cuz this guy is literally such a pro and
so I spent the rest of that day just
like overpreparing the out of my
presentation to be like okay right I
can't compete with him on this front but
like I'm going to make sure I I just add
enormous value to the audience and added
like 100 more slides to my presentation
and just make it as practical and
actable as possible um and so I guess
the anxiety was there around like uh oh
my thing isn't good enough so I was like
right let
me blow them away with Val that like I
something about this feels feels a bit
better yeah so that that that moment
where you're in the audience and you're
going okay yeah I've got myself into
some real trouble here that I think is
the closest feeling I would describe to
what I had but every day all the time
with with no power to go and prepare
something valuable because I've got to
speak right now yeah it's like that 24
hours a day that's pretty terrifying or
rather exhausting yeah yeah it's really
it's really tiring it's really really
tiring I would genuinely go to bed every
day feeling like I had like I'd done
like I'd run an Iron Man or something
you
know so to what extent is the Shina of s
social anxiety gone for you now or is it
that it's still there but you found
strategies to deal with it like how do
you how do you think
yeah so my in my in my old version of
events what I was looking for when I
called up the therapist I was looking to
wake up one day have you seen the Barbie
movie no not yet I have to see the
Barbie movie okay I wanted to wake up in
Barbie land okay I wanted to wake up in
this world where I was perfect and I
never had insecure thoughts and uh I
would wave everyone Hi Barbie hi bie hi
and they'd wave back at me you know and
I imagined this world of all my friends
who I saw who are naturally extroverted
and I imagine that in their head they
never struggle right or I see you on
YouTube and I'm like he never struggles
giving big keynote presentations to
people he's super important and people
love what he has to say and so I had
this misconception I think that it is
possible to feel nothing when you speak
that confidence means feeling nothing
when you speak and in reality I think
the most liberating thing I've learned
in this process is not
that it's not the confidence means
nothing it means feeling nothing it's
you still feel the same feelings you
still have excitement you still have
anxiousness you still get excited to go
on a podcast but what I have now is that
I know that I can do
it I know that that feeling is a good
feeling because I'm excited because I
want to talk to you and because I want
to share this message and because it
matters to me and and I'm a human and I
care and have feelings and if I felt
nothing I would be chat GPT we don't
want to be
that
so I don't think I've definitely lowered
my I've definitely lowered my anxiety
from the days where I was like running
on a treadmill only thinking about
speaking I've definitely in a much more
chill place got a lot more room to
breathe The Rock and the hard place are
like at the end of the garden now you
know and I get to frolic in between but
I still feel a bit of nervousness I feel
a bit of pressure I still feel a bit of
anxiety before I speak in something
important and I think now I think that's
a good thing it means I care solid so
then as 2021 you see this video of me
and Michael inist doing some mult
speaking games what happens next so they
were advertising their fundamentals
course and a new cohort had just opened
I think at the end uh they did a very
brief plug and you had like a little
link so I clicked on the link uh and the
the standard tier was sold out but I
just Des I was I was hooked I was like I
need this and so I I paid for the course
and I started I think I literally
started two two or three days
later and it's a it's a five-week course
three hours a week and I remember my
first session and we did a game called
rapid fire analogies where you have to
complete the sentence and I remember I
shut my laptop after that first session
and I was
like what have I just done like this is
I knew then that this was going to be
something huge for me
because it was fun and because someone
had said that I was good at it in the
lesson that was the first time I think
I'd
ever heard someone say I was good at
speaking and actually listened and
believed it
because in real life you don't really
get
opportunities to have people say like
sit you down listen to you speak and say
oh Al you're amazing when you speak
maybe maybe you get
that my day-to-day job I didn't get that
much of that people never would come
back to me and say you know when you
said this sentence it sounded so
confident or at least I wouldn't hear it
you know and so it was throughout that
five week
course I had people coaches but also
just other people taking the course say
things like that came across really
confident I really like your energy wow
you have such a fun personality and I
was like I have these
things I've had them all along why have
I been hiding them you know and so uh
just in those five weeks already by the
end of it I was a different person what
what other sort of exercises did they do
in the five weeks and I guess for
someone listening to this who
yeah maybe it's in their car or
something is is is are there any is
there anything that like someone could
could take away from the course they can
just sort of practice without having
taken the course yeah so the premise of
the course is that uh you play a bunch
of speaking games uh the idea being that
it makes speaking fun but also that the
whole that the only way to get better at
speaking is by speaking and so you get
to practice this in a fun environment
where you get a lot of feedback and a
lot of qu
feedback loops so the main games that we
played was this one called rapid fire
analogies where you have to complete the
sentence and the idea behind that one is
to get Snappy to get you out of the
overthinking phase which was my favorite
place to live in uh the phase where I
would have a thought
like wow that book looks amazing but
instead of saying it to you I would sit
there and think should I say it like
that should I say maybe something like
how long did it take you to write the
book did you enjoy the process and I
would sit and overthink and everything
so long that the conversation had moved
on and so that game is about just doing
the
opposite and training you to start
trusting the first thing that comes out
of your mouth because if you're anything
like I was you're way too
hardwired the opposite end and so if
you're listening to this in your car and
you don't have access to the games
complete some
sentences the moon is yellow
because because it's made of cheese
right amazing you know um tables are
sharp because they have legs uh toes are
wrinkly because they have skin right
like any it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter but like the premise is just
start thinking it start stop thinking
you know and and start saying stop
thinking and start saying yeah speak
before you think is what they say what
we say at alra speaking speak before you
think
huh yeah because I guess like one of the
things that I really liked about about
the course and about like the whole the
whole philosophy is
that I think
it it sort of TAPS into the intelligence
that we have outside of our brain kind
of thing kind of thing where sometimes
I'll find that that um you know I'm
doing a YouTube video or something and
it's like I'm sort of stuck in my own
mind and it's just like kind of all
these Loops of like oh this it's
not valuable etc etc but when I'm in a
live Q&A where there's a couple hundred
people on a zoom call or in real life
and I'm doing a Q&A and someone's ask me
a question I don't have the luxury of
overthinking there I just sort of say
stuff and afterwards I'm like damn that
was pretty good and I'm like where
where's all this like confidence and
power when I'm like trying to film a
freaking video why does it take an hour
to record something that's like going to
be 12 minutes long but in on a live
stream I can just I can just say stuff
and and it works and there's something
around like the more like thinking
doesn't actually help a lot of the time
yeah it does in the sense of like
sometimes useful to have structure if
you're giving a talk and all that kind
of stuff obviously but I find that even
now you know I've been I've made about
700 YouTube videos over the last six
years and even now when I hit record I
sort of start to feel like like okay
come on we got this we can do this I'll
get up make the D play the guitar a bit
be like all right come on we got this if
it's live stream is just like you know
I'm doing I'm doing a 90-minute Q&A
about YouTube later today I'm going to
be super chill with that zero prep Rock
up have a chat like be friendly cuz I'm
not in my head when I'm in my head then
it's just like light there yeah like I
have this I have this pet theory that we
are looking at speaking the wrong way
around and that if you are someone who
is let's let's take the example of
someone shy and let's say you're at of
drinks and you're sitting on the sofa
and there's people around you and
they're all chying to each other and no
one's chying to
you and you start to have
these thoughts that maybe like I'm not
interesting and someone tries to talk to
you and the conversation doesn't really
go anywhere for whatever reason they get
distracted or you know you feel like
they're turning
away in that moment it's very easy to
think okay I'm going to get better at
speaking and the way I'm going to do
that is I'm gonna be so charming and
charismatic I'm going to learn how to
sit up straight I'm going to learn how
to uh use posture use hands tell stories
be exciting uh get rid of my arms and rs
I'm going to change all of these outside
tips and tricks and then when I have
that I'll be good at speaking and then
everyone and then I'll be confident
enough to speak up at my drinks and it's
kind of this outside in approach only
when I have learned all these tips and
tricks will I be good enough to talk to
people and right now the reason I'm not
good enough is because I don't know how
to do these things I don't have those
skills and I think that's the wrong way
around I think it's the opposite I think
that in
reality I had this I heard this phrase
and um I quite like it the problem is
not the
problem the problem is your solution to
the
problem nice so the the problem here is
not your inability to speak or your
speaking ability the problem here is you
thinking you are a bad
speaker or you thinking other people are
judging you and so therefore you protect
yourself by not
speaking by staying
quiet and that is the
problem and so in reality rather than
fixing it from the outside in of like if
I do all these tips and tricks then
finally on the inside I'll be good
enough the reality is that on on the
inside you are good
enough when you speak to your close
friends to your family to your loved
ones in some
situations you're totally free I think
everyone has those places where they
they're totally free and they can speak
but then in this situation you're
not so instead of learning speaking from
the outside in of like these are the
skills I need to learn and then I will
be confident we should learn it from the
inside out I am the way me the way I am
am right now knows how to
speak and if I just unlearn all of those
beliefs I have about myself about being
terrible and and having no
value then I'll be able then I'll be
amazing um so back in the day when I was
like uh sort of early teens I would have
identified as quite shy in that you know
I would uh like the the context in which
it it came up was that that I I used to
do this sort of math teaching thing at a
place called Kumon like a study center
on the side my brother did that oh no
way I never had to apparently wasn't
good enough at math um so I was like one
of the the markers who sitting behind
the desk cuz I was I enjoyed math I was
markting stuff and helping helping kids
with their homework and I was like 14
and the sort of everyone else who was a
helper were was sort of older than me
and a lot of them were girls so like
16-year old girls 17y old girl like I
was like oh like I need to I need
to be able to maintain conversation and
stuff and I was I was very shy in that
like these were like these cool older
girls and like they're like going know
good at maths as well and like I don't
know b intim
i and I would really struggle to kind of
hold conversation yeah and so I found a
few strategies here and there like I was
at the time started watching like Gossip
Girl in 90210 great great shows and that
was a domain in which I was very
comfortable speaking about those TV
shows cuz I was like okay cool I know
these guys I'm pretty sure these guys
watch them as well like everyone I other
the time did so I can connect on that
specific plane and I would always really
struggle to just be like you know how
was your weekend or anything like basic
like that I would be like oh no I could
possibly ask that because BL blah and
then when I was um 16 we had our GCC
results day and I smashed it it was
great you know went with my mom to see
the Headmaster thought it was going to
be this big congratulations type
situation and then um after a bit of a
chat with the Headmaster he sort of he
was he asked me what I wanted to do at
University and I said I wanted to do
medicine and was like okay I'm going to
say something to you and no one is going
to say to you but I think you need to
hear it and he said that he didn't think
I would get into medicine not based on
my grades but based on the way that I
was coming across CU he said that you
know I've been asking you about the
subject that you seem to be passionate
about not once have you smiled um it
seems like you know I've been mostly
talking to your mom rather than to you
because you haven't really spoken very
much and so he was like over the next
two years I have no doubt that you're
going to get the grades but you need to
work on this sort of confidence thing
and sort of show a bit more enthus iasm
and passion for the subject and that was
a real like sort of Turning Point cuz I
was like oh like I've been writing
off the whole like I get I get good
grades by default situation for such a
long time now there's this thing I want
I want to get into medicine at a decent
University I might actually be shafted
by the fact that I'm not particularly
confident and so at that point I was I I
made a rule for myself that every single
every single class I would go to or like
lecture or anything I had to ask a
question and so for the whole thing I'd
be thinking okay what's my question
going to be what's my question going to
be put my hand up and ask a question
question and that was helpful I also
started doing close-up magic and so
learning card tricks and stuff and like
you know that was a bit of a crutch to
then show tricks to the cool kids and
they would be like oh my God like all
this kind of stuff um and through that I
came across a lot of training for
magicians around confidence I was like
oh this is what I need because as a
magician you have to go up to you know
if you're walk around magician making
money professionally at a wedding or
something you have to go to a group of
people break the I talk to them and ask
them you can show them a bloody magic
trick like the thought of that was
absolutely terrifying um there was this
uh my my first paid gig was at like a
family friends restaurant and there was
this like corporate event he was doing
at the restaurant and he was like oh you
know we could we could do with a with
with a magician going around doing some
card tricks like would you like to come
over and I was like yeah this is great
and the very first group I went up to
was this group of like 45y old gyos with
their sort of three three buttons off
like sort of Hands In Pockets like beer
in the hand sort of just like very kind
of intimidating group and I was like I'm
going to do this and I show them a magic
trick and it totally failed like I got
the thing wrong I got the MS in my head
wrong and completely died and they sort
of just sort of laughed and went back to
the conversation and that was just like
a moment of pure like oh my God I'm
terrible at this I just sort of sat in
the corner for the rest of it I didn't
even approach another group for the
whole hour and you know my my uncle saw
me and he was like he offered to pay me
anyway and I was like no no I couldn't
possibly take payment for this and I was
like okay this is a problem then I found
all the stuff around like confidence and
public speaking and things like that and
started really trying to actively
improve the skill but it was like this
the these various I guess the Headmaster
moment and then that restaurant moment
that made me realize oh this is
something that I actually need to
improve and I started reading books
about how to be more confident and stuff
and and they were actually pretty
helpful and started applying some of the
insights and ended up becoming you know
now people look at me and they're like
oh you're good at public speaking and
you speak on camera all the time and it
really wasn't like that at all um yeah
so you learned a lot of how did you
learn confidence
a lot of it was around um part of it was
mindset and another part of it was
strategy so the mindset part was you
know to to your point just now um
there's this this other magician I used
to follow who would was it was really
good but he he would specialize in going
up to a random group and like doing
magic with like just stuff that was
around him so sort of thinking on his
feet and all this kind of stuff and his
whole his whole philosophy was that
confidence is not something that you
acquire and if you have if you're
thinking of of confidence is oh I will
become more confident over time by doing
more of this thing you've already lost
cuz confidence is just something that
you can just choose like in the moment
you can simply choose to be confident
and it's almost like you know the whole
F to makeer thing but like you know in
this in this moment I'm going I'm going
to act confident and one thing that that
he would say is that there is no
difference between real confidence and
fake confidence like broadly people
cannot tell the difference and so if
you're faking confident if you're acting
as if you're confident in a social
social situation
generally people are thinking about you
anyway the pro it's going to fly like
it's going to be all good and you do
that enough times and you realize oh I
can actually just choose to be confident
I can flip the confidence switch in my
mind so there were a few mindset things
like that that I found I found really
helpful yeah and I think uh but that's
what we learned in the first week of
fundamentals it was literally that it
was you're saying absolute nonsense like
the moon is yellow because it's made of
cheese and you're saying it you're
choosing to flip that confidence switch
and people weren't noticing that I felt
like an idiot
yeah and they were saying nice things
instead and I was like hang on I feel
like an idiot on the inside and people
are saying I don't look like
one there's a disconnect between how I'm
feeling on the inside and how others are
seeing me on the outside and if that
happens here maybe that happens
everywhere that I feel nervous and oh my
gosh this whole time I've been thinking
people can see it and they just
can't and I think
that's yeah I think that helped me but
that that moment you said that the
Headmasters moment where he called you
in and he was like yeah you you you
might not get in you're doing all the
right things that I feel like I relate
to it so much it's my entire my entire
first 18 years of my existence is like
yeah you're good at the stuff that we
ask you to do but all of the stuff all
of the speaking around it is going to
hold you back and I know that there are
so many other people who get the same
feedback and I think and I think
it's unfair that there are so many
people out there
who think that they are like broken in
some way because they get this
feedback because they get
told like you and I were you're great at
the school work you're great at your job
but you're never going to go anywhere
because you don't smile enough or you're
not confident enough or you don't ask
enough
questions and the
implicit
understatement in that
is you the way you are is not good
enough and you need to learn some kind
of
skill and it goes back to thing I was
just saying of like you in that
situation I imagine that you had all the
skills already what you were learning
was the mindset the confidence right
like with your mom you were probably
quite outgoing and you did SM when you
talked about
medicine and I just think so many people
walking around
thinking I am yeah I'm broken like I'm I
an outcast I cannot speak in everyone
else can why not and it's not true I
would say it's it's it's sort
of like for me when I got that feedback
it wasn't like oh oh crap I'm broken it
was like oh my God thank you thank you
for identifying this area of my life
where I need to level up sick let's go
for it um and I think similarly if I if
I think to like my team members and you
know I've given feedback to a couple of
them around around confidence yeah and
sort of I find myself thinking that
like yeah you're you're good at the job
but when you when you speak it comes
across as if you're questioning yourself
too much and when you when you have the
questioning tone in your voice now I
have zero confidence that you actually
know what you're talking about because
you've got a questioning tone in your
voice and now I have to start thinking
about like have you actually done the
work or are you like yeah and and then I
look at the work and I'm like oh
obviously you know what you're talking
about and I think there there are little
tweaks like that where it's just sort of
you know even just like when you're
finishing a sentence finish it on like a
down rather than finishing it on an up
and it just sound makes everything you
say sound a little bit more confident
just like little things like that
because subconsciously you know a
medical school interviewer or a boss or
something
is taking into account the subconscious
cues of confidence and even just faking
a little bit more confidence makes you
sound as if you know what you're talking
about way more um I used to notice this
in in in medical school quite a lot like
there was a guy who um he was he was he
was a friend of mine his name was Paul
and he was very good um but he was he
would also say things with such
conviction yeah um that I started saying
things with with conviction I was like
this is good I started saying things
with conviction and occasionally you
know actually fairly often I'd get the
thing wrong but like I'd say it with
such conviction and people would be like
wow like I actually just believed you by
default and and then I thought about it
and then I realized that no that's just
that's actually just completely wrong
and like there was so much of it I I
think especially the girls that I was
friends with with they were all really
good but they would say things with like
less conviction and therefore you know
in that environment where lots of things
are going on they get that the the
impression that the doctors would have
is that they are less intelligent than
the guy who said things with conviction
yeah it's like there's just all these
things that are happening in the
workplace and in real life around the
way you're saying something rather than
the thing that you're saying conviction
is such an underrated energy people do
not use conviction enough I feel like
where afraid of it because it's quite a
scary energy to say I believe this even
if you're only 80% sure that you do
believe it yeah and uh it's like like I
saying it's it's almost a
self-perpetuating cycle of once you do
have more conviction then people will
give you better feedback and therefore
you will grow more confident in the
things that you do and you get stronger
but at some point you do have to just
throw yourself off the cliff and say
something with more conviction than you
thought you should and see if it works
you know this episode is sponsored by
kajabi and they've actually got
something really valuable for all of our
Deep dive listeners now if you haven't
heard of kajabi it's basically a
platform that helps creators diversify
their revenue with courses and
membership sites and communities and
podcasts and coaching tools so it's one
of the best places for creators and
entrepreneurs to build a sustainable
business we started using kajabi earlier
this year and as soon as we started
using it we were like oh my God why
haven't we've been using this product
for the last 3 years it's got everything
you'd possibly need for running an
online course or hosting an online
community or building an online coaching
business and it essentially makes it
really easy to run your entire online
business from payments to marketing
tools to analytics kajabi has everything
that we creators need all in one place
and actually you don't necessarily need
a huge audience to generate a
sustainable income a Creator on kajabi
can for example make $100,000 by
converting just 350 customers a year
depending on your price points and in
fact there are creators on the platform
that are making millions of dollars
every year with fewer than 100,000
followers across the social media
platforms we've been using kajabi to
host all of our online courses since the
start of 2023 from our $1 parttime
YouTuber foundations to help people
start off on their YouTube Journey all
the way up to a $5,000 package for the
part-time YouTuber accelerator which
gives you access to me and my team and
kajabi does not take any cut of what you
earn creators keep and own everything
the way kajabi makes money is through
the monthly subscription fee and even
though we generate like literally
millions of dollars every year from
kajabi we're still only paying them a
couple hundred a year and actually in
their lifetime kajabi have paid out over
$6 billion do to creators that's billion
with be and over a thousand creators
have become millionaires through
products on the platform now back in May
2023 I did a keynote at a kajabi in real
life kajabi Heroes Event in Austin Texas
and in that keynote I talked about the
exact steps that I used to grow my
business from zero to over $2.5 million
per year from course Revenue alone now
people paid for the pretty expensive
tickets to watch this keynote at the
kajabi hero live event but as an
exclusive deal for deep dive listeners
kajabi have very kindly offered to
provide the recording of that keynote
completely for free to anyone who
listens to this podcast so if you're
interested in getting completely free
access to that keynote just head over to
kajabi.com Ali that's kajabi.com Ali and
that'll be linked in the show notes in
the video description as well you just
enter your email address and then you
will get the recording of that keynote
completely for free whether or not you
ever become a kajabi customer so thank
you so much to kajabi for sponsoring
this episode yeah I find that uh
Americans are very good at this oh so I
think sort of Brits and
Canadians I've noticed a bunch of
Canadians do this as well um sort of we
tend to downplay things whereas when I
spend time in the US I'm always just
like surprised by how much conviction
people have
for saying stuff even if I know they
actually don't know what they're talking
about in that specific context like if
someone's if I'm if I'm at like a
conference or something and someone's
talk talking to me about YouTube and
I've I've seen their Channel and I I
know they've got like 300 subscribers
and they've been doing it for like a
month and the way they speak about about
like content creation and like growing
on social media with such conviction I'm
like wow I didn't more that confidence
in my life most of us 99% of us are way
too far on the wrong scale in terms of
conviction like pretty much all of us
and then there's a select few who could
do it with dialing it down a little bit
but I think we're also so afraid of
being that select few that we dance
around the very very much not enough
conviction area because we're so afraid
of going a little bit too far and uh I
would love to see everyone just wake up
go to the office the day and go too far
just for one day see what it does you
know yeah it's a good experiment almost
yeah um in my team as well like
occasionally I get I'll get a message
from someone being like Oh hey you know
sorry about that thing that I said I
think I might have gone too far I'm like
what they did not even vaguely register
me because to them they were like oh my
God I it was too direct with that that
thing that I said I'm just
thinking it it was it was just totally
normal like it was so normal to the
point I didn't even notice the thing but
they were all in their heads thinking
like I I said it too directly yeah cuz
the line is here right and they like
they're usually here and they went here
and oh my gosh that's way further than I
usually the line line is here you can
you can always do what you just said you
send a message afterwards if you really
think you've gone too far
sorry I went too far you'll be forgiven
yeah it's I've rarely heard stories of
someone because conviction is not an
energy that is anger or aggression or
it's not a negative energy it might have
negative connotations if you're afraid
of it but it's not like it's not
something that you are aiming at someone
else like you must believe me it's just
it's just more belief in what you're
saying more
energy and more
certainty in your in your in your
beliefs yeah okay so you did the ultra
speaking course like your life changes
in the five-week course what happens
next in your life and I guess with as a
Rel public speaking uh so then what
happens is I started leading a live
class ult speaking which is classes that
uh happen every day and I did once a
week I led a live class as a graduate of
fundamentals which meant I had a bit
more knowledge in the fundamentals and
so I'd have 10 people come in once a
week and they would be these eyes
looking at me saying Alor tell us what
public speaking exercise we're going to
practice today I felt like a total
fraud uh and so I did that for a few for
a few months I think and I loved it and
it was the scariest thing in my life to
have to say with conviction things that
I wasn't sure I had conviction on I
didn't feel like I knew enough about
public speaking to
to uh lead a class when in reality I did
I had done the exercises and I was just
giving the exercises that i' done before
you know with conviction so I did that
for a few months and then I got an email
in my inbox that said would you like to
apply for Coach
training and I remember the application
process you had to send in a video of
you coaching
someone which I found I I never coached
before I was I I wasn't a coach right
and so I found a friend and I coached
him and my most extroverted friend I
don't know why I chose that friend to
coach and you had to write a little
blur uh about 100 or 200 words maybe 500
I can't remember on why you want to
become a coach and I wrote that a
hundred
times and I couldn't get it right and
eventually I think I spoke it and I just
typed what I was speaking and I sent
that in and magically they selected me
which felt like a complete magical
moment at the time I couldn't figure out
why didn't quite have the confidence yet
to believe it and I trained with them uh
to become an OP speaking coach and
Michael and Tristan trained me for quite
a few months uh and I was coaching a lot
to get those coaching hours but I was
doing this all alongside my job because
this for me was still at the time a way
of improving my job a way of improving
my my career and my ability to ask
questions to clients he was still a data
scientist at I was still exactly data
analyst data scientist makes me sound
too important um and uh then at one
point when I'd qualified and I was
coaching I just kind of had an epiphany
where I woke up one day an epiphany
makes it sound so important but I just
woke up one day and I was
like what I'm learning from the coaching
is lifechanging for me
and to be able to see people change in
front of my
eyes in the space of an hour it's like
way more meaningful with anything else I
could do in my life and so I quit the
job became a full-time coach yeah nice
with ultra speaking with ultra speaking
and I still work with ultra speaking oh
nice how long has it been uh so that was
in August of
2021 yeah nice so two it's it's my
twoyear anniversary there we go D so
it's like Zoom sessions or real life or
like Zoom sessions real life if they're
in London yeah I'm head of the London
Europe Branch if anyone's around and
wants and wants speaking coaching yeah a
lot of it over Zoom as well and and
running the fundamentals course now uh
that the one that I took nice that's
pretty cool it's super fun yeah it's
super fun it's a it's a full circle
moment for me to come back here and and
and talk to you oh that's cool because I
found them through you so yeah I wonder
if um we can go over the
the various Concepts that the ultr
speaking people or that you guys at ultr
speaking teach and if we can just Riff
on some of these let's go for it so
we've got um musicality what is
musicality as it relates to public
speaking well
it's similar to I mean the reason we use
the word musicality it's similar to in
music what makes it interesting is
partly the interpretation of the piece
right you play you play musical
instruments don't you yeah the devil
with piano guitar yeah and they have all
of these uh instructions about how loud
it should be and how quiet it should be
and how it should sound and it's the
same thing in speaking if you speak in
one emotion one energy level one tone we
call that monotone it's supposed to be
not a good thing and it can be like
being constantly excited and you you
know you have this People You Meet who
are like always excitable or really
really quiet really really calm what
we're looking for with musicality is a
bit of contrast a little bit of movement
between the energies so that you can
express yourself in a way that matches
what you're saying so that when you care
about something you can have a bit of
conviction about it so that when you
want to think about
something you can talk about it in a
thoughtful and reflective way so
basically it's about matching what's
coming out on the outside with how you
actually feel about it on the inside so
that people can understand that's how
you feel about it um what is the the one
thing
concept this is this is an important
concept so the one thing concept is this
idea especially when you're preparing
for a presentation that your
audience after a week let's say when
they go home to their partners and they
say oh I went to this really interesting
presentation that Ali gave it was
about right and they're going to give
their partner a one- sentence
summary and so when you're preparing
your
presentation the first thing you want to
think about is what do I want that one
sentence summary to
be and it's the same when you're
speaking off the cuff if you can what is
the one message you want to get
across that's good yeah that's good I
should do more I should do that with my
Keynotes I'm just thinking that ah that
would be a good kind of unifying thing
to hang everything else off of and that
just makes it it makes it more
memorable yeah if there's one thing I
want you to take away from this it's
it's this and that's and you can have
all your stories and your anecdotes and
your data and that can be supporting
branches off your one thing but I think
I certainly used to have this tendency
to want to fit everything in because
there's so much important stuff and I
want everyone to know everything and in
fact all that does is it it uh
clouds your presentation it confuses
rather than ads so choose one thing and
then build it out from there rather than
the other way around yeah this's very
much applies to bookwriting as well
where like you start with the you start
with the hook is like what is the one
thing that this like what is this book
about and like asking an auth the
question of what is your book about is
like a very anxiety inducing question
because a lot of people are like oh God
like it's it's actually surprisingly
hard to answer that question cuz like
well it's about this it's about this
it's only like the the real pros
understand that like you need to know
what your book is about like that one
sentence hook before you start writing
it otherwise you're going to go off in
weird directions um and like certainly
with this one you know like the three
three year long process link down below
um the threee long process of writing
this all the way through was this
question of like what is this actually
about what is the one message and for
future books now that I've kind of gone
through the process once I'm like all
right cool we're not I'm not even going
to begin to write until I know what the
one message is like what is what is the
hook what is the preferably what is the
title as well because this title feel
good productivity only came like two
years into the process
and it kind of like the title informs
The Hook and the hook informs the way
that you structure the content in a way
to make to make everything support the
hook and you could be saying the same
thing but it would be sort of packaged
up in a different order and in a
different way if the title was different
and so there was a lot of like sort of
radical surgery we had to do once once
we got the title to be like okay let's
make sure that this title is you know
the one thing that people take away from
the book is that you know to be
productive you try and feel good with in
your work or something to that effect or
feeling good about your work makes you
more productive like yeah that's a broad
summary yes there's all sorts of nuance
there it's not quite the thing it's like
kind like with the atomic habits small
changes lead to Big results that's what
the book is about and then it's a really
good book beyond that but the thing you
remember is that small changes lead to
big El he's got a little graph of like
exponential compounding and it's the
thing that people remember no one
remembers the four laws of behavior
change but what they remember is that
habit stacking I remember habit stacking
habit stacking is another another one
people do small changes to Big results
um so I think there's a lot and in a lot
of different areas this idea of like
what is the one thing you were actually
trying to say it's just really helpful
but then do you think you knew it before
you wrote the book The one thing or do
you think you discovered it as you wrote
the book yeah I did discover it as I
wrote the book uh but that I also made
the mistake of not like doing the
research I I trying to do writing and
then research then writing then research
a future books I would do research
outline right which is just sounds so
obvious and sensible when I say it now
it's just like initially I was thinking
oh I've made videos about this
before like I can just bash a book out I
got 10,000 words and I was like okay
I've run out of things to say now I need
to go back to the research papers and
stuff and doing it in like that way
around I think was suboptimal so yeah
with speaking is a lot easier because
you can just speak right and speak speak
speak and then say let's say you set a
timer for five minutes you got to give
like a 10-minute presentation set a time
of five minutes speak for five minutes
okay that's roughly what I want to say
set a timer for two and a half minutes
do it again set timer for one minute set
timer for 30 seconds right oh that's
good this is It's the accordion method
and it's an amazing method for preparing
your presentations you basically step
down the time so you can start with 20
minutes half the time every time step
down the time constraint and what that's
doing is it's forcing you to get rid of
the stuff that's not important and keep
the one thing that's important so by the
time you get to 30 seconds you've got a
one sentence one thing and then you can
step up the time
constraints and add the stories back in
and add the data back in and see what
you feel is valuable to keep but
basically it's about refining your
message on the go to discover what it is
the one thing that you want to say that
is a really good idea I love it a good
method nice okay I'm I have a keynote
coming up I'm speaking at uh Google in
Ireland like next week or the week after
so need to do a keynote about the book
okay well I'll share there's a link for
a course online on alra speaking that is
just takes you through that method so
I'll share the link you
nice recovery what's what if what
happens when you make a mistake when
speaking that is I think one of the
biggest mistakes that beginners make
when that new to speaking is that
if is that when they make a mistake they
let it get to them and they let it
affect the way that they speak so for
example let's say you stumble over some
words if you're a beginner you might
notice that and start apologizing sorry
sorry let me start again right and what
you're doing when you apologize for the
way that you're speaking is you're
drawing attention to the mistake that
you're making
and there's lots of different ways to do
this some of it is literally saying I'm
so sorry can I start again some of it is
nervous giggling some of it is we call
it breaking character basically coming
out of the
confident conviction version of you and
into the apologetic version of you
and what that does is it doesn't allow
you to recover from the mistake it means
that the mistake becomes evident
obvious and then it takes a huge amount
of
momentum to get back into speaking once
you've stopped I know that for me like
when I'm speaking it's all going and the
ball is rolling down the hill and
everything's amazing and then when you
stop it takes a bit of a activation
enthalpy or whatever it is to to get
over that that hurdle again
and so I was watching a I was watching
Simon T next start with Y at Ted Talk
the other day and I just think he's a
phenomenal speaker he has a lot of
conviction and he and I saw about 5
minutes in or 3 minutes in I think it is
he it's a very small stumble but he
stumbles over the word organization like
why does your organization exist or
something he says why does your
organization exist and uh it's
completely imperceptible because he
doubles down on the word exist exist and
then he carries on with his message and
he gets even more excited and brings
even more energy and even more
conviction but
you could equally do the opposite
stumble over the word organization get a
bit in your head stumble over the word
exist and and kind of crumble and the
distinction between great speakers
and starter or beginner speakers is not
the amount of mistakes they make
although it does reduce it's the fact
that great
speakers recover from their mistakes
much much faster than beginners do so
what are some strategies for
recovering there's a few different
ones one of the ones to recover from a
mistake one of the ways to recover from
mistake is just to up your energy so
like Simon SED in that presentation you
stumble over a word just bounce into a
little bit more up your conviction a
little bit more and use that momentum to
throw yourself into what you're saying
to double down on it which might feel
scary doubling down on a mistake that's
one way to recover another way to
recover is take a breath if you're
stumbling if you're feeling a bit lost
just take a breath take
two and then start again from a
different angle another way to recover I
love these summary
prompts a summary prompt is a sentence
that you can use to prompt yourself as
you're speaking so a little bit like we
were doing earlier prompting ourselves
with that a table is sharp because it
has legs instead of a nonsensical
sentence it's a sentence that will trick
your brain into completing it so a
sentence like the important thing to
remember about this is the one point I
want to get across is I guess what I'm
trying to say is in short in
summary and if you ever feel like you
are rambling or you're making some
mistakes or you're kind of struggling
with the direction of your
speaking take a
breath and basically what's important to
remember about this is
you don't necessarily know what it is
that you're going to say but you've
prompted your brain and your brain will
complete the sentence as you go and it
just redirects you with a little bit
more clarity nice silence what's the
role of Silence when it comes to
speaking I think there's an obvious role
for silence which is that from the
outside it makes you look more
confident I think if you think about
really important people they are
not I mean they're on their own
time and everyone else is waiting
for them to speak right and so if you
look at someone like Barack Obama he has
uses a lot of silence and a lot of
pausing and I think Executive
presence is something that's very
related to pausing and silence and being
the one who has the guts to take a
breath basically the important thing
about silence is that in that moment of
pausing you are unbothered you are
confident that your
message is worthy of listening
to and that people should take the time
to not interrupt
you and let you finish your thought
that's the exterior part of Silence it
gives you more confidence but then I
think this is even more fascinating the
impact on your thoughts
silence and in particular breathing is
the only time you really have in your
speech to check in and
rigate
so silence allows you to take a
pause and maybe change
direction maybe discover something new
about what you want to say so uh let's
say you
are describing why it's important to be
productive and you get halfway through
and you're like I'm missing something I
don't know what I'm missing but I'm
missing something take a breath take a
couple of
breaths maybe a thought comes up to you
and you're like don't like that one put
it aside it gives you a little bit of
time to let the thoughts come and it
gives you a little bit time to go
actually you know what I just said
that's not the most important thing
about productivity this is the most
important thing about productivity so I
think silence is good for confidence
externally but it's also the most
important thing you can do to actually
navigate your speaking on the Fly and I
guess we're often reluctant to take
pauses because in us to to our mind a
pause feels way more long than it does
for the audience it always feels longer
it's it's exactly the same as before
conviction feels louder you know
confidence feels harder pauses feel like
hours to you and Nan seconds to your
audience so if you want to practice your
pausing pause for way way longer in your
practice than you think you ought to you
can set a timer for like 20 seconds and
watch it go down as you pause you can
hold your hands up yeah and count your
way through through the pausing it feels
way longer
to to you than it does to your audience
but also it feels really scary to say
something and put it out
there and just let that it um selft Talk
what's the deal with selft talk the deal
with selft talk
is kind of like what we just talked
about
with the example you were saying of
sometimes I just tell people to be 20%
more confident or add 50% more
conviction and more energy and it
changes the way they speak well what
that means is that the skill set in
those people is already
there so most people's skill set in
speaking is already really good there
are very few people I meet where I'm
like you have a major skill set
deficiency in your speaking i' I'd
rarely rarely ever see that but for a
lot of people the mindset is a thing
that's holding you back and so a lot of
the work that you're doing and you're
speaking is your skill set is up here
and your mindset is way here how can we
catch that mindset up to your skill set
and that is where the selft talk comes
in if I can simply
say to a client like I said
earlier that was awesome people liked it
and then the people in the room say wow
yeah you came across so friendly you
came across so smart so intelligent and
they speak again and they are coming
across a hundred times better purely
because they've heard the words you're
coming across so smart and so
intelligent then so much of speaking is
selft talk I would go so far say 90% of
speaking is in the way that you think
about yourself rather than the skills
you
have I guess what we're saying is that
it's useful to think of yourself as more
confident than you feel or like more
authoritative than you feel it is I uh I
listen to I don't know if you've heard
this's this clip on YouTube with
Michelle OB talking about imposter
syndrome and she describes it so
beautifully she says you know it's that
it's that feeling that you have when you
feel like you don't belong and she was
saying I've been I've been pretty much
everywhere I've been in all the biggest
rooms of the world I've met with the
most important people in the world and
I've been in all these incredible
situations and at the start she said she
used to walk in and feel like a bit
intimidated like she didn't belong and
then at some point she looked around the
room she looked at all these men around
her and she said no actually it's you
that doesn't belong you know you're the
one I I belong here you're you're sping
and a bunch of nonsense you know and uh
just that's just the mindset shift right
that's just her walking in the next day
and realizing that actually all these
thoughts she's been telling herself
about not
belonging not necessarily true and she
has just as much value to be there as
anyone else and so part of it I think is
is
just treating yourself as if you have
more right to be there than you think
you do I sometimes say to myself what
would Michelle Obama do I like it I
think she's awesome you know and I'm
like how would I act if I was if I had
all the experience and the gravitas and
the and the love that Michelle Obama has
how would I walk into a room and I find
that helps me just in the moment to pack
myself up a little bit more but the
other part of it is more experience you
have doing things that scare you so
speak speaking under pressure and
surviving it and not only surviving it
but thriving during it the more you will
know that you can do
it nice um a few more questions from our
telegram Community uh so we've got a
question from Mil who says how do you
have any tips to getting out of your
comfort zone more and pushing yourself
um they say I'm fine when I chat to
people but I won't ever start a
conversation because I'm comfortable
just doing my own thing
yeah I'm fine when I chat people but I
won't ever start a conversation
okay there's a bunch of different things
you can do for that I like your one of
you made a rule that I'm always going to
ask a question you know I say that
sometimes I say that uh whenever you go
somewhere just raise your hand you don't
even know what you're going to say yet
just raise your hand and then you got to
say something right so make
a commitment to yourself kind of a a
commitment to yourself to speak and it's
better if you can do it by tricking
yourself I.E by raising the hand before
you know what you're going to say
because then you know you got to say
something but if I'm sitting there the
whole time I go to I went to talk the
other day and I was like I'm gonna ask a
question I'm gonna ask a question a
public speaking Co I'm gonna ask a
question and I sat there the whole time
my hands were down and people other
people were asking questions and I was
it was getting towards the end of
question time you know and I was
thinking oh God I'm running out of time
to ask question I'm running out of time
and there was a moment where I would
have let it go and I was like no I can't
do that stick your hand not you know
Force trick yourself into doing the
thing you want to do that's one thing
the other thing I would say is uh join
join a club like join a toast CL Toast
Masters Club join Ultra speaking go to a
place where you can practice speaking in
a comfortable environment that is
separate from your life where people
care about you and improving speaking
and giving feedback and all of that
stuff in a way that feels very low risk
because if you're trying to improve if
you're speaking in the real world with
friends that you care about and work
that you care about it can feel like a
lot of pressure it can feel really
really scary but do it but you do need
you do need those reps you do need to
speak in a different way and feel the
difference and be rewarded for that and
go through that feedback loop enough
times to have the confidence to do it in
the real world so find a place where you
can do that whatever it is yeah I find
that
um you know when I'm about to stick head
up to ask a question or to volunteer
something I I I'll always feel that
moment of indecision to be like oh you
know is even a good is it is it worth
like I don't know and then I almost
always think that like who who is the
sort of person I want to be someone who
asks a question or someone who is afraid
of asking a question then the Au is US
clear like okay I mean even if they
don't pick on me even if they don't like
even if whatever it's
like I
have it's it's a win for me if I put if
I put my hand up to volunteer the thing
um and again at this conference I was at
last week you know the person sitting
next to me was like confused about
something and she was like I'm not sure
if I should ask I was like yeah put your
hand up and ask cuz like he's asking
questions from people during the talk
and she was like no it's you know it's
it's probably a dumb question I'm like
no you know thing is a dumb question
like and she didn't ask the question
because there was all the all of the
fear and the indecision and the oh but
like I'm sure it's a stupid question I'm
sure not I'm sure I'm the only one yeah
thinking like who who doesn't understand
the difference between operating cash
flow and free cash flow or whatever the
thing was and I was like no it's
genuinely confusing like I would have
for you to answer that question yeah um
that no but so this I struggled with
that a lot especially in my journey to
becoming a coach so I went through this
phase of when just when I was in the
early phase of my
training uh I was confident in speaking
i' done my ultra speaking I could speak
to the clients yeah
but part of
being a coach is also being able to like
figure out what's going on underneath
right and so I remember I ended this
session and I was being observed by
Michael and Tristan because I was still
in coach training I ended this session
and it was a really underwhelming
session like I hadn't got any real
meaningful change in in the client they
hadn't shifted in the way they were
speaking and I ended it and I remember
Michael said he said what were you what
are you looking for you what were you
looking for in this client what was the
one thing that you think was going to
change that speaking
and I remember I was thinking well they
were saying that it
was uh they were saying that it was
about uh them them not speaking up
enough at work you know they were saying
that it was about them not speaking up
enough at work but whenever we
did the Reps they were supposed to do
they were doing it perfectly and I
couldn't like understand that disconnect
and in that session instead of asking
them a question or saying the Bold thing
like saying hey I'm noticing that you're
saying you can't speak up but when I ask
you to speak up you speak up what's
going on there I just fluffed around the
thing and wasted 45 minutes of our time
when that one question would have
unlocked everything right and I think
it's
the it's the same thing in like in
everyday situations which is that
one question can completely change the
course of a conversation that instinct
you have about
like I don't understand this this
doesn't make sense there's something
that's off here probably everyone else
in the room is having that instinct and
if you don't ask it you're now
wasting the next 45 minutes out like the
the rest of this
conversation
because there's something missing for
you
M um we have a question here from Molly
in our telegram Community as well who
says how do you get over thinking that
everyone is judging you or thinking that
you're stupid in social
situations um how do you be yourself
regardless of the people that you're
with get over thinking that people are
judging you and thinking that you're
stupid in social
situations it's fine I want to say you
don't like I want to say
it's sometimes I do feel like I've said
something stupid you know and and that's
okay it's normal uh so part of it I
think is getting over this expectation
that one day you'll feel perfect right
uh but to answer that question
properly I think it's a combination of
pretty much everything we've talked
about so it's going to be look for
evidence of things that you're doing
well most of the time if you're feeling
judged or whatever you'll notice that
you're only picking up on the things
where they prove the fact that people
are judging you look for evidence that
people are enjoying time with you do
they invite you back did you get invit
how did you walk into that party in the
first place like someone invited you
right they wanted you there and so look
for evidence and every time that you
speak make it a mental framework
to Pat yourself on the back oh I did
this thing well and then you can judge
all the bad things you did if you want
to but make it a priority to think about
the good
that you're doing that's one thing the
other thing is uh actively ask people
for good feedback on your speaking
either by going to to join a club where
you're speaking in front of them or just
in general ask your close friends what
do you like about me like what what what
what are the good things in my
personality because so often I
will I I think 50% of my job is just
reflecting back what I see to
people they just come in they speak and
I say has anyone ever told you that you
come across
like this wow I've never heard
that you know
so ask for
it um another question from Brian from
our community uh is my lack of
confidence seems to be holding me back
from pursuing opportunities and
connecting with others are there any
specific techniques or exercises you
recommend to gradually boost my
self-esteem um and then follow up how
can I work on challenging negative
thoughts and beliefs that contribute to
my feeling of inadequacy ah come to
outra speaking I'll help you but if
that's not an option I think I would
say so what if you're struggling with
confidence and
self-esteem the first thing you want to
do is to build yourself up step by step
so I think the main mistake I made when
I was first in my kind of socially
anxious phase is that I was expecting
myself
to do everything that everyone else
could with the same amount of ease so
for example we would be sitting at a
restaurant with my mother and I would
get a dish that I hadn't ordered and she
would say I I'll call the waiter over
and send it back for someone who
struggles with shyness that is basically
the end of the world like I would rather
I I I would rather crawl into the ground
or Sprint out of there run to Timbuktu I
don't know what it like you know I I
can't handle that situation and I think
um a lot of the challenges you see
online are around that kind of thing of
like challenge yourself to do something
scary go into a coffee shop or ask
someone for $100 or something like that
and uh if you're struggling with
self-esteem I'd say start
small start with one tiny little change
that you can make in your day and nail
it you know nail it so maybe it is uh
using one summary prompt at the end of
your morning briefing with your boss and
saying so the one thing I did this week
that's the most important is
and say that with confidence and turn up
your conviction and nail it right and
pat yourself on the back and look at the
evidence for how well you did and then
do that again and add something else to
it and then do that again and add
something else to it
but just work up there slowly a little
bit every day rather than like trying to
do something terrifying and it being a
traumatic
experience nice I think another thing
that I find helpful for self-esteem is
to recognize that almost everyone thinks
that they're not good enough like
literally almost everyone does it's not
it's not it's by no means an original
thought um
and this at one point um my my brother
and I have this podcast that we do on
and off and at one point we interviewed
uh well we we we had a guest on who
who's a friend of mine who was um one of
the quote cool kids at University in
that you know gymgo alcohol drinking
socially like extroverted kind of kind
of vibe and the this was a few years
after we' graduated so we we were asking
this guy be like like what's it like
being one of the cool kids like what
does that look like and you know he was
he was on the the sports teams and
what's good at all of the things that
you'd associate with like you know a
sort of quote cool kid and it was really
interesting because he was like yeah you
know I'd go to these parties often and I
I feel like I don't belong because I I'm
I'm not I'm not drinking as much as the
next Guy and um or i' you know I'd go to
this thing and think that well you know
I'm only like on the third team for you
know tennis rather than the first team
so it's like you know obviously there's
some sort of social me there and he also
said that in he he kind of went into
these events think feeling left out and
then he after speaking to people over
time he realized that everyone sort of
felt like they didn't belong to these
events and they were all sort of putting
on a little bit of a show but when
everyone in a group is putting on a
little bit of a show you get the
impression that you're the only one
who's like feeling as if you're putting
on a little bit of a show
um and yeah increasingly as I've as I've
come across more and more people through
you know the stuff that I do and just
speaking to people just is the feeling
of inadequacy and lack of self-esteem
and stuff like almost no one has it in
Spades it's like everyone is struggling
with it to some degree in some domain
and so yeah I think just understanding
that you're not alone I I always find
find to be really helpful it is like one
of the most human things I think it is
what distinguishes us
from other animals is that we have this
ability to reflect upon ourselves and
question ourselves and question the
things that we do and uh
overcoming selfesteem issues
is a lifelong battle I think for for all
of us it's not something that you click
your fingers and it happens overnight
you know okay um I guess final thing to
talk about is what like let's say
someone's got to the end of this this
podcast I think we've been talking for
like over two hours now so you know
they're clearly vibing with stuff they
we're talking about here and they're
thinking cool yeah I I do feel a bit shy
I would like to be more confident I
would like to be H at speaking what are
maybe kind of the top three things three
actions that they can take from
immediately after listening to this that
they can start applying to their life uh
put down the podcast listen to all the
other episodes first watch all of Ali
abdal stuff then put it down put down
the book and find a situation in which
you can speak you will not improve your
speaking without
speaking that's a fact and I'm sorry but
it's true so find a situation in which
you can speak preferably Under Pressure
because there's no point practicing a
situation that you feel comfortable in
and preferably with feedback right so
that's the first thing you can do and
and there's loads of clubs and stuff
online available so I would
say that's the that's basically the main
tip I would give you the second tip that
I would say
is so I was chatting to my sister
yesterday and she's asking me how's your
week looking what are you up doing I I'm
going on this podcast tomorrow I'm going
to talk about social anxiety I'm going
tell all about my journey about being
shy just like oh wow that's so inspiring
what's the one thing you want them to
take
away classic sister okay uh and I and I
gave her this really inspiring spiel
about shy people not being broken and
and it being really uh really a great
thing to be shy and I want people to
feel not alone and and not struggling in
that and you can overcome it just like
me you can overcome it all of this stuff
and she just looked at me blankly at the
end and she's like well that sounds
horrible M that sounds like a really
unpleasant two or five years that you
had overcoming your fears it looks it
sounds like a really miserable time and
I would not I'm not inspired to do what
you did because you're asking me to get
up every day for the rest of my life and
do something that scares me and I was
like
okay I think I forgotten something
really important which is that it's fun
speaking can be fun that uh look for for
the ways that it can open up
opportunities for you in this journey
not only have I become a public speaking
coach and changed my career I've also
changed my life I have better
friendships I um went yesterday to I
went yesterday to a coffee shop to work
to I was writing out some ideas for a
new public speaking course that we're
going to launch and I was really excited
about it and I opened up my notebook and
I sat I had my tea and I was ready and
and uh I looked at my bag and I didn't
have a
pen so off drink my tea do some emails
and I decided I'm going to go to another
coffee shop but on the way I'll stop off
at a store and buy a pen walk into Muji
dangerous place to go into because that
is like productivity Central you feel I
just felt like if I buy 20 boxes and
organizers suddenly my life will be
better so I walk in there and I come out
with 23 worth of
pens normal right all the different
colors of the rainbow go to my coffee
shop open up my notepad lay out my my
pens in front of me and start writing
and it's one of those coffee shops that
has communal
tables and this lady about 10 minutes in
comes up to me and she says hi excuse me
excuse me and I'm thinking she wants to
sit over there cool of course you can
sit there and she says excuse me do you
mind if I sit here and I borrow one of
your pens because I forgot my pens
today I thought oh so I told her this
story about getting conned by Muji and
buying all the different pens and she
found it hilarious and she's writing a
book and she was making all these edits
in her book and for me it was just a
really wonderful moment of connection
with a random human who also forgot her
pens also get sucked into thinking that
if she just buys 20 pens she'll be more
productive and it brightened my day
and that's I
think
what's important about improving or
speaking it's fun like you're going to
get to meet really fun people and talk
to them about pens that's cool H nice um
speaking of fun I was thinking it would
be nice if we can play some of the some
of the games um I would love that so
these games are freely available on
ultras.com um you don't need to sign up
to the course to play them you can just
play them for free um and I think the
games are really helpful we do we do
sometimes play them as part of our
YouTuber Academy when we're doing
sessions on like confidence and things
like that I'll just bring up like triple
step or ratify or to complete or
something like that and and we'll make
it happen so um if you're watching this
on the YouTube video you'll be able to
see the screen recording of the iPad as
I bring these up if you are listening to
it on podcast players then some of this
will require using your imagination um
but I wonder if we can start with rapid
fire
autocomplete Okay cool so we've got
triple step conductor rapid fire
autocomplete rapid for analogies or
complete with breath the podcast we play
podcast I love po that one yeah we
should have warmed up with that one yeah
let the podcast game Okay cool so um
what like timer one minute
difficulty let's let's make it random we
that number of players there's two of us
Yeah the more the marrier with this game
it's going to suggest the title right
and it's going to suggest the title yeah
absolutely cool so we've got two players
and so what's the what's the premise
behind the podcast the premise behind
the podcast game so the idea is that
there's a number of you and you are all
talking on a podcast y uh and the game
is going to come up with your name and
my name and when your name's on the
screen you're talking when my name's on
the screen I'm talking the thing about
this game is that we're trying to talk
as one unified voice so when our name
swap over I'm not saying oh Al that was
such a good point yeah you know tell me
more about that instead I will just
finish your sentence I'm literally
completing your sentence and the idea
behind that game is to get out of your
head okay because most of the time when
we are speaking in conversation I don't
know why you would definitely mean back
in the day all I was thinking was what's
the clever thing I can say next and I
would completely forget the person in
front of me saying something clever
right now so this game it's all about
focusing on the person in front of you
staying in the moment and trusting that
you can complete their sentence without
preparing it in advance cool let's give
it a go let's give it a go so all right
if money didn't exist if money didn't
exist I think that I would be doing
exactly the same thing in life because
it's a good question to ask yourself
like if if money didn't exist how would
that change how you spend your time
because a lot of us do spend a large
amount of our time working on things
doing stuff purely for the sake of money
and we can end up in this Zone where you
know depending on what our job is 8 to
12 hours of our day could be spent doing
a thing that doesn't fulfill us that if
money didn't exist we wouldn't be doing
the thing and so I find that to be a
really interesting question like a
journaling prompt another way to think
about it is if if
you work up tomorrow and you
had
and you had nothing left what is the one
thing that you would go and buy would
you buy your family would you buy your
friend like what is the one thing if you
had only money and nothing else in your
life what is the one thing you would
wish you could buy back that is the
thing you should be focusing on not
money nice that's all bad that's fun
that's yeah that's fun okay so let's try
another game um I like the podcast game
because you get handovers like that
where you're like I really don't know
what you're about to say
yeah um um okay let's do blindfolded
slideshow oh love this one difficulty
fast okay you can go first amazing this
is your blindfolded slideshow so what's
the premise behind BL blindfolded
slideshow is you've turned up to work
your colleague is sick and your boss has
said you have to take their presentation
in front of clients you don't know what
the presentation is you don't know what
you're supposed to say but you're going
to have to give it as if it was your own
and so in this game you're going to get
random slides coming up on the screen
and you're going to incorporate them in
your speaking on the Fly and make it
sound intentional nice cool so we'll do
difficulty fast time of 50 seconds it's
going to suggest you a title that's
going to be nice and fast okay yeah the
title is what's the most addictive to
addicted to a game you've ever been I've
recently become really addicted to
playing chess online I feel like I'm
climbing up these stairs to finally
become good at chess and opening up my
Horizon to being the kind of person I
wish I was when I was 11 and I competed
at chess and my brain was burning and
exploding and everyone was judging me
because I was losing all the time now I
feel like my brain has exploded I'm old
you know like I've run out of things to
do but at least I can sit at home open
the window and challenge myself play
chess it feels kind of like putting
jewelry on you know like I'm suddenly
sparkly like I've cleaned my brain when
I'm playing chess because it's like
being outdoors reconnecting with nature
it is like putting the pieces of your
life together
and finding
what challenges you for me challenge is
the most important thing and that is why
I'm addicted to playing chess that was
PR good thank you very much would you've
been able to do that like when you were
in your like not in front of people
right uh would I have been able to do
that skill set wise probably most I I
think pretty much everyone can do that
skill set wise I've never really had
someone who struggles with it most of it
is the pressure you put on yourself and
the panic and like my gosh that's
another that's another image coming up
on the screen M nice that's cool all
right let's do one more we can do I well
let's do one of the rapid fire ones oh
yeah so uh let's do rapid
fire
analogies actually no let's do trip no
let's do okay let's do rapid oh cond
conductor oh oh oh uh what would you
recommend uh conductor is a different
kind of game so that's an exciting one
to show I do like triple step CU it's
just the most fun for me personally
um yeah okay let's do triple step I'm
I'm wary of conductor because I
currently have a sore throat so I don't
want to lose my voice we protect your
voice for the podcast protect the
podcast Okay cool so triple step oh
multiplayer multiplayer very nice what's
what survival mode oh my goodness this
is the best okay if ever you have like a
fun afternoon in the office and you want
to like do something fun triple step
survival mode is basically where uh
everyone so your name comes up you do
one repord triple step someone else's
name comes up they do want and you can
have as many players as you want
but every time that someone a rep the
time gets slightly shorter and they add
on another word and so at the end of
every session it says they survive which
means did they fit in all the words and
did they uh you know say what they
wanted to say and then eventually you
get to this stage where you're in 20
seconds trying to fit in like 25 words
it's just it's chaos and I love it all
right s let's play Survival Mode number
of topics let's
go let's start with four topics
and oh we can do more than that we can
do more that oh yeah yeah yeah six
topics and 30 seconds oh gosh okay yeah
a minute okay uh a minute will be long
thoughe will be long toping 30 seconds
six topics in 30 seconds two player
survival mode why not why not give it a
go let's do it okay Z you a paradigm
shift the biggest paradigm shift that
I'm going through right now is I'm
trying to eat healthier because I want
to stay around for a little bit longer I
want
to eat watermelon not only for the
pleasure of it but to feel good about
myself I want to be better at chess and
uh sometimes I wake up in the morning
and I feel like I've lost a tooth and
I've been sitting up all night eating
popsicles because I'm like so grungy
from the lack of stuff that I'm doing
but really I should just get a job take
a nap and become healthier nice
solid you did survive okay my robot best
friend my robot best friend these days
is chat GPT absolutely incredible piece
of software it's like a treasure Trove
it's like I've got I've got this map
where I can just navigate you know
whether I need to learn about horse
racing whether I'm talking about I I'm
losing a tooth it's like it just gives
me such an honest representation of what
a robot would be thinking which honestly
adds a lot of diversity to my life a lot
of the people that I know if it sort of
feels like you know we're on a bridge
and maybe you know these are Lululemon
wearing yoga pant like wearing type
people but Chad GPT add so much
diversity to my life I love it okay
you're good at this game you're good at
this game I've got competition now I
feel a little bit of pressure all right
behind the scenes uh behind the scenes
in my life this morning you would have
seen me uh trying to listen to a
meditation video and failing because
really I don't play Nintendo I'm a
little bit afraid of becoming addicted
to that when I have kids I'm going to
ban them from watching the TV but I'm
socially distanced from all of this
listening to rap music and getting a
massage people say you should do really
if I'm being vulnerable and breaking the
eggs to make an omelet I should do more
meditation damn that was very good
it's getting scary fast isn't it it
getting very fast most interesting
person I've ever met the most
interesting person I've ever met is a
lady called alienor it's like I was
playing on my Nintendo this morning I
was eating like a bunch of popsicles and
I just you know came across her and she
was teaching me how to do public
speaking it really felt like I was
eating chocolate that's how much kind of
Joy I got of this out out of this thing
you know initially last night I was
having some expired pickles I was like
roaming around in my jacuzzi and was
like oh my God I can't do it it's gone
I've died we're getting into extreme
mode now I we're getting into extreme
mode oh my gosh okay taking CL plants is
the worst thing I'm really bad at taking
care of plants worse than listening to
politics I feel like I have this engine
inside of me and all my plants just
flush down the L I wish I could time
travel and sit on foam rollers and make
my plants not stick to the carpet
because I'm like a monkey when I play
with them they're fasting they don't
have any water when I invite dinner
guest arounds They're laughing at my
plants because they're like a broken
finger they're wonky I can't look after
plants wow okay I think you're you're
the you're the clear winner over here um
GG that's PR good I love that game wow I
love that game wow man I thought I was
good at this but like just been
absolutely trounced it was great um so
these games are available for free on
Ultras speaking.com and if you're
watching this on the YouTube video
you'll be able to um kind of see what
was happening on screen as we were
playing those games um it is a better
experience when you see see what's
happening on screen so if you are
listening to this on the podcast then do
have a look at the YouTube channel if
you're interested in kind of seeing what
these games look like um any final word
wisdom word parting words for anyone
who's who's got to the end of this
podcast yeah thank you for getting to
the end of the podcast uh my final words
of wisdom would
be everyone's
different like take the pressure off
being certain kind of person like being
perfect you know if you're listening and
you're thinking I struggled with that
shyness too I relate to that moment in
Tesco or I relate to that moment uh
where you were
pressing the doorbell at the dentist
then I would
say you have
strengths and we've been talking about
today about just about the weaknesses
because that's kind of the the whole
point of a podcast is say how to improve
your speaking and if you're bad at this
do this and if you're bad at this do
this but uh if you listen to the end of
the podcast and you're that dedicated to
improving your speaking close the laptop
right now and text three
friends ask them what is my strength and
open up a piece of paper write them down
stick that potit on your wall on your
laptop and have a nice day nice thank
you very much thank you very much all
right so that's it for this week's
episode of Deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are going to be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye-bye